United States and others have worked
with their private with their private
sector
on contracts to build new nay Sands in
other air defense equipment
and I applaud the countries that are
finding ways to meet Ukraine's urgent
air defense needs
and we will stay laser focused on this
task
and during today's meeting several
allies and partners also discussed plans
for training Ukrainian Pilots
on fourth generation fighter aircraft
including the F-16
and planning and executing this training
will be a significant undertaking
but the coordination of this contact
group will help make that possible
and I especially want to thank Denmark
and the Netherlands
which have decided to lead a European
Coalition in providing F-16 training for
Ukrainian forces
in the coming weeks my Dutch and danish
counterparts will work with the United
States and other allies to develop a
training framework
Norway Belgium Portugal and Poland have
already offered to contribute to
training
and we expect more countries to join as
important initiative soon
the starting work on the F-16 training
now is an important example of our
long-term commitment to Ukraine's
security
third the contact group discussed
long-term sustainment of our support
that includes industrial initiatives and
coordinating our work to ramp up
production of critical equipment
I appreciate the work of the national
armaments directors
who meet under the auspices of the
contact group to ramp up industrial
production and I look forward to doing
even more together
and today members of the leopard tank
Consortium
discuss their progress in setting up a
maintenance Hub and furthering their
efforts to Resource this important
program for years to come
so we got a lot done today
but we are by no means done altogether
and so we're not going to let up
today's meeting has again shown the
contact group steadfast support of
Ukraine
and that's because nations of Goodwill
don't want to live in a world where
autocrats can invade their peaceful
neighbors with impunity
so we're going to keep strengthening
Ukraine's position on a Battlefield
we're going to get Ukraine's Defenders
what they need when they need it
and we're going to remain United
we're going to stand by Ukraine for as
long as it takes
again and now let me turn it over to a
general Millie chairman thanks secretary
and good afternoon everyone as secretary
noted this is our 12th meeting of the
Ukrainian defense contact group and this
group stands as a very powerful symbol
of the international solidarity in
support of Ukraine and it made possible
really due to the leadership of
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin
without his leadership this would never
have began 12 iterations ago and it
certainly wouldn't have been sustained
for well over a year so thank you
secretary for your leadership and thank
you also to all the ministers and Chiefs
of Defense from 50 Nations that
participated today virtually and that is
a statement of real unity in my view I
also want to thank Ukrainian Minister
defense resnikov and Mike counterpart
who I talk to very very frequently
General zerlusny and also his rep who
was there today General mosia their
leadership remains steadfast The Bravery
and the courage of the Ukrainian people
is exemplary and inspires literally the
world and their courage and Tactical
kill in the face of extreme adversity is
second to none today marks the 456 day
since Russia began its illegal and
unprovoked invasion of a free and
independent country called Ukraine
Putin envisioned a swift Victory a quick
dissolution of the Ukrainian Spirit a
conquering of the government a capturing
of the city of Kiev and pretty much
three quarters of the entire country
he could not have been more wrong the
Ukrainian people remain Resolute and
their spirit is unyielding the Battle of
bachmood is just one example for nine
consecutive months Ukraine has fought a
very successful defense and exact did a
tremendous cost on Russian forces and
that was due to Ukrainian courage in
their tactical and operational skill the
Ukrainian forces continue to fight
and they're making the Russians pay
severely for every inch of Ukrainian
ground Ukrainian resistance is not
fueled merely by weaponry and Manpower
it's fueled by the unbreakable Spirit of
freedom and democracy Ukraine continues
to defend its sovereignty with strength
and courage and recently we have seen
the Ukrainian Jews the U.S Patriot
missile
system air defense system to great
effect these systems Have Been
instrumental in protecting the Ukrainian
Skies bolstering Ukraine's defenses and
contributing to the overall
effectiveness of the Ukrainian fight
the proficiency of the Ukrainian forces
in operating these systems as fast as
they did is Testament to their skill and
adaptability under pressure
it's another example of the ukrainians
leveraging the tools provided by the
International Coalition into the
tangible success on the battlefield from
anti-tank weapons like javelins in the
beginning of this fight all the way to
Patriots today and we'll soon see the
same with f-16s but this is not just
about military success it's about a
larger battle a battle about the
principles of sovereignty and democracy
it's about standing up against
unprovoked aggression and upholding the
so-called rules-based International
order every nation that was there today
underscores the importance of these
principles that have been in effect
since 1945. Ukraine continues to prove
that the spirit of freedom is Resolute
every day the ukrainians Showcase the
world their unwavering commitment to
uphold the values of freedom and
sovereignty
this week the president United States
released the United States 38th drawdown
package
with additional High Mars ammunition
artillery rounds anti-arm systems and
additional support Vehicles these
Munitions and vehicles and weapons will
strengthen the Ukrainian offensive and
defensive capabilities they enable the
ukrainians to hold Russian forces and
supply lines at risk they raise the cost
of Russia's continuing war of aggression
the United States along with our
partners and allies continue to train
Ukrainian forces to enable their success
on the battlefield as well
we will continue to support Ukraine's
fight today as well as their future
capabilities to defend and deter
aggression in the future
as the president and the Secretary of
Defense have repeatedly said we the
United States stand firmly with Ukraine
our commitment remains unwavering we
will support Ukraine as the president
and the secretary have said for as long
as it takes until Russia ends this
unprovoked aggression we will continue
to uphold the principles of democracy
sovereignty and the international rule
of law thank you and I welcome all of
your questions thank you both gentlemen
our first question will go to Associated
Press Tarka
thank you secretary Austin and chairman
Millie for months we heard a firm no on
f-16s to Ukraine can you tell us how and
why your thinking changed on this and
why wouldn't the U.S now send its own
Jets air defense capability you saw us
talk about that a number of times and we
saw the reason just recently why we were
so focused on that and the capabilities
that we've managed to put together as a
result of what we provided and also what
what our allies and partners have
provided
if you can see are very impressive and
they continue to grow it's not enough
we'll continue to work on it and we'll
continue to work to create follow-on
Force capability for the ukrainians as
well
we we've provided nine brigades nine
brigades of combat capability platforms
and trained troops and I'd point out to
you that that's as big as many of the
western Nations have in their land
forces okay so this is this is not
trivial but it's not done we're going to
continue to work to generate additional
capability going forward in terms of
General Brown uh he is a an incredibly
capable and professional officer and
what he brings to the to the table uh to
any table is is that professionalism
that deep experience in warfighting and
I I have personal knowledge of that so I
think General Brown is gonna going to be
a great officer going to be a a great
officer in any capacity that he's in so
and Tara on the on the F-16 piece uh you
know what's the problem to be solved the
problem to be solved is control of the
airspace uh and Ukraine has demonstrated
that very effectively in the last year
and a half the fastest quickest and
cheapest way to control that airspace
was from the ground you can either do it
from the arrow from the ground and
providing effective uh uh integrated air
defense systems at the low altitude
short range mid-altitude mid-range and
high altitude long range that is the
most effective way to deny air
superiority to the Russians and that's
exactly what they did and if you look at
f-16s 10 F-16 is a billion dollars he
has a sustainment cost another billion
dollars so you're talking about two
billion dollars for 10 aircraft uh the
Russians have a thousand fourth and
fifth generation Fighters so if you're
going to contest Russia in the air
you're going to need a substantial
amount of fourth and fifth generation
Fighters so if you look at the cost
curve and do the analysis the smartest
thing to have done is exactly what we
did do which is provide a significant
amount of integrated defense to cover
the battle space and deny the Russians
the airspace and that is exactly what
happened and that enabled the ukrainians
to have success on the ground in ground
maneuver in the defensive battle as we
go forward f-16s clearly have a role
Ukraine deserves a capable Air Force
it's going to take a considerable length
of time to build up an Air Force that's
uh the size and scope and scale that'll
be necessary I've known CQ like like
secretary Austin has for a long time
he's a great officer in my view personal
view
he has all the knowledge skills
attributes to do this job and he has the
appropriate demeanor and he's got a
great chemistry with obviously with the
president sect deaf and others so cq's
absolutely superb and I am looking
forward to a speedy confirmation
next question will go to Dan lemoth
Washington Post
gentlemen thanks for your time today
Mr secretary the announcement on the on
this F-16 plan raises the questions what
complementary roles the United States
might play in it be it the provision of
F-16 weapons U.S Personnel in the
training program anything along those
lines how do you envision that going uh
and general Millie we've seen a
continued evolution in which the U.S
holds back certain platforms f-16s tanks
things of that sort
only to eventually agree part of that
has been risk escalation we have been
told over and over again
from that standpoint from a risk
assessment standpoint how do you see
this moment as different now thank you
well Dan I I would just tell you that uh
our approach you know to providing
security assistance to Ukraine
for the last year plus has been to
follow
an international approach where we we
get contributions from everybody that
can contribute
would not
conceive of doing business different now
differently now I mean that's that's the
way we've operated across the board
you know I've talked to the Ministers of
defense of the Netherlands and uh in in
Denmark and talked about you know what's
necessary to frame out uh the training
plan and we also talked about the fact
that I mean they recognize also that
training is one thing but to have a
capability you need you need sustainment
you need maintenance you need ordinance
so all of that will be worked through
you know with the with the committee
going forward there and a committee will
be led by uh Denmark and uh in the
Netherlands but it's a it's an
international effort and as I said
earlier you know we've seen other
countries very quickly step up to the
plate and want to contribute so
so Dan I would offer a couple things to
everything we do uh no matter where it
is around the world we're always looking
at the cost benefit and risk uh and
f-16s there's no magic weapons in War uh
and and and sometimes certain things uh
get labeled as you know this is going to
be the magic weapon there are no magic
weapons an F-16 is not neither is
anything else and as we look at what the
problem to be solved in at the beginning
of this war it was a defensive fight
against mechanized armored uh forces
Russian forces that were coming across
the border what do you need for that you
need to have to armor weapons you need
lots of them and you had to keep the
airspace clear of Russian close air
support uh that would enable Russian
ground maneuver and that's exactly what
was provided so it's not a question of
we agree later or agree now or under
pressure that's not at all with what's
getting done here this is hardcore
military analysis that looks at cost
benefit and risk and what is the need on
the battlefield now and in the near
future f-16s are much longer View and
again as I said in the beginning you
need a significant number of f-16s or
fourth or fifth generation Fighters and
the pilots to go with them and the
sustainment costs and the missiles and
the maintenance all of that package if
you were to do that just f-16s you
wouldn't have tanks you wouldn't have
Bradley's you wouldn't have anti-armed
weapons you wouldn't have anything else
you'd spend all your money on just that
so it's a cost risk benefit analysis
that leads you to these uh separate
incremental sort of uh packages that go
forward in addition to what we're doing
with the International Community it's
not done frivolously and it's done
totally in coordination with our
counterparts in Ukraine
you know Dan sometimes when we have
these conversations it sounds like
Ukraine is losing uh on this on this
battlefield
that's not the case Luke Ukraine has
inflicted significant casualties
on on the Russian forces they've they've
destroyed an incredible amount of
equipment and so and this is this is
before
we provided them with the capability
that they're getting now so this is
additive and hopefully it will put the
ukrainians in a good place to be able to
change the Dynamics on a battlefield and
uh so we'll see that that's our goal to
make sure that we've done everything we
can to put them in the right place to be
successful
thank you gentlemen next question will
go to Idris Ali Reuters
chairman Millie it's been uh several
days since the attack and incursion um
into belgrad
um there have been social media images
videos and pictures showing us-made
military equipment and vehicles being
used in it
um after your conversation with the
ukrainians and your own intelligence
means were us-made military vehicles
used in that incursion and how did the
militia get them did the ukrainians
provide them with those vehicles and
equipment and Mr secretary um this
incident and other recent incidents
including the Drone attack near the
Kremlin has that raised concern for you
that the Russians could use incidents
like these as a pretext to broaden the
war and have you talked to your your
Ukrainian counterparts about potentially
limiting the attacks that they're
carrying out closer to their borders or
within their borders for the time being
so uh I'll just very briefly just let
you know that I've got the staff looking
at that with the UConn staff to confirm
it tonight so I don't have an answer for
you right this second uh the rules that
we have established with the ukrainians
is to not use U.S supplied equipment to
attack into the geographic space of
Russia
um and look at their country at War it's
an existential threat they're fighting
for the survival I can't say with with
definitive accuracy right this minute to
you whether that and I saw the same
videos whether that's U.S applied
equipment or not it was a nature of the
attack who did what to whom I can't say
that with definitiveness right this
minute but I can say that we have asked
the ukrainians not to use U.S supplied
equipment for direct attacks into Russia
why is that because we don't want uh
this is a Ukrainian War it is not a war
between the United States and Russia
it's not a war between NATO and Russia
this award between Ukraine and Russia
and we are supporting and supplying and
help training and Advising and assisting
Ukraine but it is not a direct conflict
between I mean the United States and
Russia
I can't say it any better than that
Idris in response to the question that
you asked me
um in terms of
um
you know any kind of pretext to broaden
the War uh that Russia would make use of
I I don't want to speculate but I will
tell you that we are focused on giving
Ukraine providing Ukraine the capability
it needs to be successful in defending
its Sovereign territory and uh and
that's that's a conversation that we've
had with our our counterparts uh on a
continual basis uh We've engaged a
number of times on this issue just to
make sure that that to the Chairman's
point we are not at war with Russia this
is this is Ukraine's fight our goal is
to make sure that we're doing everything
that we can to make sure uh Ukraine is
successful
question will go to Louis Martinez ABC
thank you um can I ask you both uh this
from what uh general milley just said
it's about the investment in f-16s just
for 10 f-16s it sounds like it's going
to be a considerable budget uh necessity
uh just to keep a small uh
Cadre of aircraft flying can you get
that level of support from the Congress
for even more aircraft or even more
additional support uh you know
maintenance sustainment does this open
up a whole new series of questions about
how much funding you actually need for
the fight Beyond just the ground fight
the artillery the ammunition that
everybody needs and there's a major
debate going on in Washington right now
the debt ceiling
the possibility of a debt default what
potential impacts could we see on the
force we heard this on Monday from some
of your peers General milley about the
possibility that this is going to affect
Readiness one actually called it
potentially catastrophic what are your
thoughts on that and how is it going to
impact service members and their
families
um yeah so first in terms of the cost of
f-16s it's no surprise to anybody that
this will be expensive and uh chairman
and I and and my undersecretaries have
been you know clear about this
throughout
um
I want to thank Congress for its
bipartisan support that we've enjoyed
you know throughout our efforts to
provide security assistance to Ukraine
and the Congressional support as you
know is a major element in in our
ability to to help Ukraine in the way
that we have
I'm also you know the conversation that
I've had with my counterparts you know
as we begin to frame out requirements
for training and maintenance and
sustainment is that this costs money and
and not every country has f-16s or is
able to chime in uh in terms of training
or maintenance and sustainment but they
can provide monetary assistance and so
what I think you'll you'll see our
colleagues look to do is establish a
fund so that other countries can
contribute to this overall effort but
again this should be an international
effort and I think because of that I
think uh you know hopefully our Congress
will be supportive as they have been
throughout uh going forward
on the debt ceiling piece Louis um
you know I'm not an economist uh but I
think uh if we defaulted that would be
have significant Economic Consequences
which would then translate into National
Security consequences uh paying troops
the morale of troops uh weapon systems
contracts uh all of that would be
impacted Readiness clearly would be
impacted so our large-scale exercises
that we do at various training centers
would probably the Slowdown come to halt
in many many cases so I think there's no
doubt whatsoever that there would be a
very significant negative impact on the
Readiness morale and capabilities the
United States military if we defaulted
and didn't reach a debt ceiling uh thing
as well as reputational damage
internationally and so on I think I
wouldn't characterize it I wouldn't use
words you know to say catastrophic or
not a non-economist but I think would be
very very significant without a doubt
and it would have absolutely clear
unambiguous implications in National
Security last question very quickly
yep
sorry sorry we gotta move on last
question Tom Bowman NPR Mr secretary you
talked to some senior officers retired
senior officers and they're kind of
confused about the strategy here
is it to help Ukraine win a decisive
victory over Russia or is it more modest
and try to get them a better hand at the
negotiating table and for General Millie
Henry Kissinger recently gave an
interview to The Economist magazine he
said both Russia and Ukraine will have
to give up territory in any deal both
will be dissatisfied but he worries War
could erupt again because Ukraine is
being so heavily armed and they also
have quote the least strategically
experienced leadership in Europe your
thoughts on that
so in terms of the goals and objectives
of Ukraine's campaign we'll let the
ukrainians decide what that what that
will be our goal as I've said so many
times is to make sure that we're
providing them what they need to be able
to defend their Sovereign territory I
would remind everybody that this is a
country that's in a fight in a pretty
significant fight and what we've been
doing and it's really Artful and I
applaud the ukrainians on their ability
to kind of grow into this
we've been taking troops out of the
fight and training them on sophisticated
platforms and then putting those troops
back into fight all while they're
fighting and while this seems uh this
seems simple uh to many it is very very
uh complicated and not without risk and
so there's you have to balance the
scales uh throughout and the more
sophisticated that equipment gets the
more critical that the training the
maintenance sustainment becomes and so
again
we have been focused on giving them what
they need to be successful and uh you
know as things evolve our security
assistance has evolved over time as well
so Tom thanks for asking a very easy
question from
the former National Security advisor
Henry Kissinger so uh I I looked at the
yes I saw that 100 years old so uh look
at um it would it would uh take a lot
longer than the few seconds I have the
answer that that question fully I I
would just say this for for the time
being all Awards come to an end sooner
or later and they either come within one
side winning or the other side winning
or they come to a negotiated settlement
uh this War uh militarily is not going
to be won by Russia it's just not there
are strategic objectives that they laid
out which was the conquest of the
Territory called Ukraine the unseating
of the zelinski government the capture
of Kiev those strategic objectives went
away uh a year ago really uh shortly
after they invaded when Putin readjusted
his strategic objectives to just grab
luhansk and and the Don the whole donbos
area so the Strategic objectives that
Russia set out to achieve are not
achievable militarily they're not going
to be done at the same time the
Ukrainian strategic objectives are to
liberate
all of Russian occupied Ukraine there's
a couple hundred thousand Russian troops
in Russian occupied Ukraine uh that
might be achievable militarily but
probably not in the near term so what
does that mean that means fighting is
going to continue it's going to be
bloody it's going to be hard uh and at
some point uh both sides will either
negotiate a settlement or they'll come
to a military conclusion at some point
in the future and we'll continue to
support Ukraine and its fight for its
own freedom but as to his particular
comments about giving up land not land
Etc that's for those political leaders
to decide it's certainly not for me to
decide at a press conference in the
Pentagon thank you both gentlemen this
concludes our press briefing today thank
you very much for attending thanks
everybody